et je vais lancer le tournoi alors il va
falloir que je crée la haine tournons en
club
à rennes comme arena la pièce comme
france timing 5-0 aujourd'hui début
13h15 et durer 90 minutes donc deux
parties de et ben voilà c'est créer ça
va partir
donc la chaîne et là tout est bon on va
mettre le trust là attendez je me suis
emmêlé les pinceaux avec mes trucs wave
alors nous voilà c'est ça c'est le bon
chat donc salut à gaby n'a tort le grand
je vois je suis en train de tout bien
réglée sur mon ordi à l'aréna est de là
deux personnes ça va rentrer petit à
petit le chat il est là et il me manque
plus que l'autre chat pour mettre le
poste et on va être bon
n'hésitez pas à éclore le chat ainsi est
déjà arrivé mais on va être bon çà et là
comme fr et voilà c'est parti ça juste
hasek
bonsoir à toi bonjour à toi plutôt on se
retrouve on sort on s'y retrouve plus le
jour et la nuit à paris je fermais la
porte ça lui soit et la top on ne s'y
retrouve plus là tellement de choses
tellement de stridences mans autre chose
qui se passe c'est cool ça lui chess new
biz et ce soir d'ailleurs à 20h on fera
les parties avec avec mathieu
j'écris à michael justement l'astre
imada
vargas et mathieu qui me parlent
attendez je vais baisser les macha en
fait je faisais ma toile sera matin à la
start up et salua poulet haricots verts
aliot poulet haricots verts et salua
tard hall g de l'écho j'ai de l'éco
vraiment il ya des co c'est rare que
j'ai de l'écho j'en ai jamais eu je
crois
sachez qui dit y'a pas d'écho un peu il
ya vraiment un peu d'écho non
sérieusement oui
non non on va dire que non parce que je
vois pas pourquoi il devrait y en avoir
essayé beaucoup de gens qui écrivent que
non pour moi oui j'ai jamais de fonds
vers 6,6 si j'utilise parfois un tout
petit peu là d'où il pourrait venir
c'était comme c'est bizarre mais il y
est d'habitude ou pas où ces nouveaux
placements de micro mais j'ai rien j'ai
rien changer du set-up depuis depuis des
jours et des jours le micro il est réglé
pareil tout est réglé pareil c'est
étrange
d'avoir deux fenêtres ouvertes ma voix
est bizarre ouais c'est peut-être juste
ma voix qui est bizarre aujourd'hui un
mois moins grave peut-être je sais pas
c'est ce que j'ai beaucoup parlé j'ai
une voix de robot bon ça m'a donné envie
de m'écouter pour voir on va voir ça
j'ai l'impression que je sais pas si
vous me trouvez ou pas on vous met trop
laid c'est pas possible c'est pas un
troll on écoute et je vais je vais
écouter parce que vous me lasser mieux
non mais c'est un fake c'est pas
possible je n'ai rien changé
aïe aïe aïe
quand il n'y a pas un mot de quoi c'est
impossible de savoir après
c'est des gens qui se foutent de ma
gueule c'est pas possible il ya rien ans
mais maintenant je suis sûr qu'il ya
rien de toute façon je vais mettre ça
devant moi on est sûr qu'ils à rien
c'est bon j'ai fait ça en armes et vous
trop lié c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
non mais dis devrait vous troyer l'eia à
vous est irrécupérable quoi vous fait le
coup ça c'est le pire truc qu'on puisse
faire un streamer le coup de l'éco parce
qu'en fait tu peux vraiment pas de
vérifier et en fait tout ce qui est
genre visuel du stream ou quoi
normalement je le vois le son c'est
plusieurs ce que tu es obligé de mettre
le cazal et checker et tous nos mutants
fait ça aussi je peux voir que je suis
pas but bon alors que l'insee camille de
jouer l'aréna on verra bien et l' écoute
bonne chance à les batwa remet le lien
j'aurais bien au fond derrière une place
des cocotiers bakou tu vois le truc
c'est que sur pias comme pour la peine
ça fait raccord avec le logo de chaises
comme verre sur verre
objectif du jour battre poupine à tort
c'est un bel objectif
c'est quoi le plus petit et l'eau qui a
déjà gagné l'arène et je sais pas mais
tu as une chance avec un petit et l'eau
puisque tu joues contre des joueurs de
ton niveau donc tu peux la gagner et
théoriquement mais ça lui manu guignard
salut manu objectif du jour pas de
technique
est ce que c'est vrai que tu triches est
parce que c'est un gm qui disait ça eh
ben c'est pas vrai mais écoute s'il ya
des gens qui rage et qui va le dire ça
c'est leur live your life i'm et multi
me liste seller life qu'elle pétrole
qu'on ait faite ne m'a pas vraiment trop
les deux ours non plus hein mise à part
des trucs comme ça avec les chat mais
rien de rien de fracassant
pourquoi maintenant fait tout seul tu
parles de quoi futures sur 50 secova
rénale tournant exactement un jet je te
remets le lien hop un sens amis parce
qu'en fait on va plus tourné en fait du
coup au lieu que au lieu qu'on fasse
tous les jours ensemble comme ça je
ferai cinq jours sur sept
voire même quatre jours pour plus trouvé
en fait
et fab et mathieu c'est une question de
budget aussi les gains mais en fait vous
pensez vraiment que tout est toujours
gratuit ça c'est un truc de ouf on fait
ça c'est un truc que je pense que vous
avez vraiment du mal à intégrer les gars
ça c'est un truc vraiment vraiment
difficile à intégrer je crois que sip
bref que s&p ouais faut que myspace
pourquoi pas c'est vrai c'est vrai
pourquoi pas celle après le truc c'est
que ça me travaille pour czech comme
avec pour faire les traductions et tout
donc c'est aussi pratique quoi en fait
tu as l'impression que tout est toujours
gratuit en fait c'est un truc de ouf
bah non c'est pour ça qu'on s'a bonnes
bases et font pas déjà plaint que j'ai
ce cas il faut déjà plein de trucs qui
peuvent pas face à une société qui veut
qui est là pour perdre de l'argent quoi
qu'il faille y faire ils n'ont pas un
budget illimité 1
c'est comme ça et je pense iam des 16 à
9 que je pourrais pas couvrir way le
carlson à 8h au drame mais bon après
tout on fera un peu de repos par rapport
aux événements couverts on en compte
déjà tellement l'arrivée des candidats
les matchs 1 les trucs avec nous pas un
cours sur les business models un jour
voit ya pas vraiment de business model
chaise comme je sais pas ils font leur
live je suis pas dans leurs comptes
sains mais à moi pour mon truc district
en gros ces jeux stream beaucoup et je
gagne pas grand chose quand on voit le
business model mais on peut pas tout le
temps avoir des causes c'est tout le
temps avoir des gens et tout ça tu vois
c'est pas c'est financièrement pas
possible en fait quel est ton plus grand
rival streamer et je sais pas je pense
pas vraiment voire deux rivales
david roussel je pense pas je pense je
m'entends bien avec plus ou moins toutes
les chaînes qui sont là depuis longtemps
je m'entends bien avec les bras
fondamentalement il car gros si on se
parle rarement mais j'ai pas nouvelle
relation botez je fais les petits raid à
chaque fois elle est très heureuse ça et
mode j'ai parlé quelques fois il est
sympa donc non ça se passe plutôt bien
ça se passe plutôt bien
en gros avec robert est ça se passe même
très bien on s'écrit de temps en temps
et non et non il ya aucun petit n'y a
personne qui m'a rien appartient comme
iam des cézanne à la personne qui me
propose rien sauf la fidh avec qui j'ai
déjà fait le championnat du monde
du coup et lala et la fédération avec
qui on fera d'ailleurs jeudi une arena
jeudi soir une arena bitstream 20h30
normalement ça va être confirmé avec
avec les avec les frais de la fédé donc
en vraiment se passe assez bien en
général
mais on sait déjà que ça rapporte pas
des matchs qu une audience constante
depuis de 5000 joueurs commençaient ap
ap ça dépend des langues et des pays
sly la taupe genre par exemple si fede
stream en anglais des chèques à partir
de tout appareil de chaque genre les
bras il fait entre 500 et 1000 personnes
sur les lives et ils ont trois mille et
quelques semaines dont trois mille et
quelques cèpes ça va tu commences déjà
moins ça commence déjà à être cool mais
en vrai en france je pense qu'il
faudrait être entre deux et trois mille
je pense déjà entre deux et trois mille
si tu fais des moyennes à 2,3 milles je
pense c'est déjà pas mal
voilà je pense que tu dois bien galéré
ça va ça va
bah écoute m des 16 à 9 faut que tu que
tu leur propose cette idée mais je je je
pense pas forcément que ce soit à leurs
délires le prime en france et le manque
de partage les laïcs way c'est vrai
qu'en france ces gens là et que moins il
s'est moins dans notre culture c'est
comme ça les interrupteurs vous en êtes
où
faut demander à ses amis ça va demander
à ses amis mais je crois que c'est déjà
il a clôturé les inscriptions je crois
qu'il ya 11 12 équipes de mémoire et
déjà une combien de cours d'échecs par
semaine environ à moi maintenant stream
plus justement parce qu'il ya plus de ça
avec et plus de temps mais a abandonné
entre 15 et 20 par semaine maintenant
entre 8 et 10 8 et 11 entre 8 et 12 9 8
et 12 on va dire est-ce que j'ai créé
mon équipe non non non non je veux pas
participer à tous les trucs le tueur
tueur c'était des équipes limitées de
vue par 8 et du coup c'est pas
communautaire donc et le lien je vais te
le remettre delta one
là oui c'est vrai qu'en france saleilles
que moins que dans que dans pas mal
d'autres pays après c'est une question
de culture mais du coup toutes les
chaînes sont moins laïque et donc à la
rigueur je pense qu'il ya ça ça doit
savoir revenir au même au final quel est
ton plus grand rêve en tant que streamer
un plus grand rêve en tant que streamer
mais en fait c'est ça fait tellement
longtemps que le stream que non mais
juste ça continue comme ça que la
communauté grandit tranquillement que le
chat soit toujours cool de refaire des
belles soirées comme on avait fait à
paris en avril dernier la ça c'était
vraiment sympa
non juste continuer à voir en fait je
parle on rêve à proprement dire à part
continuer à avoir une communauté sympa
et passer passer des bons moments
ensemble et et ouais ouais enfin comme
ça quoi
un multi vis à vis mon sourire un jour
ensemble et là tu pars du mauvais pied
quoi dans le sens où tu meurs août une
liste de base il ya des gens qui disent
que je triche du coup on ne sait pas qui
d'ailleurs lui qui a des grands maîtres
qui disent ah bon on ne sait pas qui on
tu veux stream je sais pas à quoi tu me
parlais un peu un peu étrange mais multi
beast et lien pour le tournoi the cosby
plutôt le mais c'est quand il a commencé
à fait qu'il soit qu'il est fils peu
quatre ou cinq ans qui retransmet posant
unifiée noise f 4 des 5
d'accord je connais pas trop la
viennoise pour dire ouais
dames 2 sur les viennoiseries sanchez r
ouais moi aussi car oui même bien ce
fait la taupe
il est bon esprit les créations des
joueurs en associant ses gants vêtements
illizi vrai c'est pas ultra lisible bon
ils sont 2000 et moi je te défendre il
étudie pas et tu te dis pas qui c'est et
multi beast c'est les gens qui s'assure
des stream ou quoi on voudrait savoir
maintenant si vie qui va jouer le
tournoi donc vous des deux bon je sais
pas j'ai du mal à comprendre les
planches dans le sens que ça va pas trop
parce que leurs dames et leur fout là
c'est dans le mauvais sens les gars
weathers toujours attention quand vous
développez une dame comme ça en e2 ça
peut être un tu vois rien de fait une
partie comme ça j'ai développé ma dame
on le sait j'ai émises en b 4 après ça
allait mais là du coup faut peut-être la
dame elle rebondit son dessin pour que
le foyer en d3 mais les dames qui bouge
comme ça c'est un peu c'est un peu un
peu difficile il va se prendre des elfes
600 cavaliers français 3 pour doubler et
la dame qui vient en recettes pour aller
vers a trois fils et c'est bien on me
sort après ce qui doit lui faire foule
pour pas se faire doubler les pions
tu as peut-être envie de mettre le
fougueux 4 à la plage en face les
français trois fois eux quatre que tu
touches la dame au passage ouais ça
c'est hyper logique et maintenant
l'action prend 1 5 avec le cavalier h4
qui rôdent peut-être cavaliers f3 du
coup faut revenir travailler changeant
de 500 revenir avec la dame en deux sets
est peut-être la dame va venir se placer
par la suite un gène l'espagnol ça sent
quand même le mytho à une multi beast je
te dis ça je dis rien salut cave j'ai vu
que le temps des candidats allaient
reprendre
c'est vrai il ya une date là écoute
moment il n'y a pas de date et c'est
censé être vrai oui qui va reprendre
mais il n'y a pas de date ya pas plus
d'informations que le fait qu'il dise
que ça aura quoi et ça lui car aimer le
style ont dégagé le niveau est moins
fort ouais aujourd'hui c'est un peu
moins à voir mais quoique il ya cette
joie qui joue il ya maugrée fola et non
c'est pas moins fort il ya d'autres il
ya d'autres joueurs forts en fait c'est
fort différemment aujourd'hui
publicis à lui je te suis sur youtube je
t'ai découvert avec les vidéos d'ap sol
après enfin sur ton live j'aime beaucoup
ton énergie force à toi merci aux
qu'humaine 78 et n'hésite pas aussi du
coup apollo ma chaîne perso il ya un
lien juste en dessous donc il mais qu'il
ya valiant f3 et areva se pendre la dame
cette la dame en a 3 il ya les cavaliers
qui vont venir qui vont rodez ya la
casse b2 la l'ouverture des blancs
étaient un peu catin et salue suricates
us c'est qui s'est passé cette joie
cette dame b 5
ok on va voir comment ça va continuer ce
que puis on prend 1,5 à tout moment tu
peut transposer à prendre en f3 prenant
prendre là mais bon il ya des saints qui
va tomber
donc je pense qu'il va reprendre du
pillon quand même bon il va il va perdre
le pion de toute façon les prénoms ses
katas mais pourquoi c'est si mal passé à
quel moment
[Musique]
dames 2 ça me paraît juste bizarre si tu
veux faire dame de autant tu mets ton
fou en bessin qu'avant et tu fais d'un
bep 2 après damas doa prépare dont
c'était bizarre de mettre la dame devant
neuf et là je pense au lieu des quatre
n'aurait plus été tenté par des trois
cahiers français 3b c'est bon c'est pas
l'amérique mais j'aurais plus été tenté
par un truc comme ça
bon il a récupéré ab7 du coup marianne
mille et une manières de prendre
l'aventage
c'est la méthode américaine je sais pas
trop ce qu'ils écrivent
salut mon gré fallen séance quand elle
s'est elle-même au greffe au lake
colonne quoi ça qui est drôle d'endroit
question c'est un à trois rois des deux
forcé roy béria trouver 8 et vidaillat
d'amd de aussi pardon ah oui les changes
comme ça il a rien dû trouver de
concluant il veut jouer la finale voyait
mais est ce que c'est bien vrai tu
reprends tu reprends la et surtour point
f3 fou g2 et pour essayer de jouer du c4
peut-être ce qu'on n'aurait pas qu'un
film + 1 dans cette finale est ce
qu'elle est si simple je suis pas sûr un
après la fessée 4 c'est quoi le problème
là dessus
touraille 4 mais tu fais c'est 3 l et
tourcoing est froid tête pour fou j'ai
deux tours f2 ou des trucs dans ce genre
là bon il va être le fond c'est qu'il
rate il protège la deux ok faut deux
temps il a un poumon avec les blancs
mais elle est pas si clair clair un
tourin enfoncé tout seul coup tout
reprend h 2 ok tu pouvais roi prend pour
prendre 2 tu prends prend et tour ses
quatre tours proches de torrents c7 et
onction avance vite quand même il est
plus perdant maugrée il a voulu rentrer
dans la finale ok prendre en prend et
tour à 3h 3 mais tu fais nul
tours à trois tours de la pure h3 et le
truc qui dira ok tu mets ton pions h4 je
pense c'est hyper soupçonnant ce qui
fait mètres la tour ans et cède ses
mauvais aller devant le pion c'est très
bizarre sa technique maintenant
peut-être qu'il va essayer de monter le
roi a sacrifié la tour contre le pion et
gagner avec les pions ça me paraîtrait
soupçonnant ce qui fait il veut avoir
tourné deux eaux
incroyable mais tours d2 est ce que ça
va être ça devait faire nul émanant c6
c7 cevital et ouvre cette partie
incroyable que maugrée les perdus
incroyable
incroyable c'est ouf de chez vous
comment comment il sait faire tourner
maugrée tiens on va regarder cette série
je suis super bien ça a eu 35 106 65 et
le lien pour le tournoi il est là hop
salue la capote masqué salut frank zappa
un enfant d'avoir dit merci donc celle
qui est un excellent joueur de double
enquête au franchement forêt qui me
donne des cours là dessus il est
vraiment très très très très très bon
pour pour jouer ce genre de position
c'est un joueur très très pénibles
on a utilisé à tort le chat on a besoin
de beaucoup de 2,9 avec melanie lee a
bien réussi quoi il ay la school vis à
vis à vis très cool cavale et h5 ifra
dam des deux fous prend b2 prix je veux
juste illustré en mettant pions sans ses
cadres tout reprend et cavaliers avec
6.3 sexy pour montrer il va jouer le fou
comme ça qui fait la focale sur le
cavalier et qui va venir jouer à l'ailé
dames avec des idées justes de damas
trois tours à quatre choses comme ça et
le pion à 6 c'est très difficile à
défendre ce que le fou prend beaucoup de
cases et juste ca va être un problème
d'éviter ça pour les noirs c'est un
avantage stable à long terme et à saab
il est excellent dans ses positions et
saluer thann dans le chat et salua air
maximus 31 mai ouest c'est vraiment un
orfèvre de ses positions et salue
poupine à tort alex verson mais c'est
vrai que son niveau est juste dingue et
salua mndm carlos et salua soya il ya
vraiment beaucoup de nouvelles personnes
sur sur s'escrime à 2010 de personnes
que je voit pas habituellement
mais je les revois pas le soir en fait
marc en fait
je ressens qu un public différent entre
les arènes de l'après midi et du et les
stream du soir ensemble qui confinement
par man s'est imposé midi au boulot oui
on est juste c'est marrant parce qu'en
fait ces gens là tu la vois pas le soir
il est pas si bien classé sur chaise
comme c'est par rapport à toi un web
peut-être qu'ils jouent moins motivés ou
juste que il un jeu plus stratégique et
- arnaque en finale pas un acquis
techniques en finale tirée à bien la
souris tirait bien pour le petit jeu
tactique
moi j'ai vraiment bon signe pour le
blitz
parce que c'est ma chaîne de tri venant
cg une autre chaîne de ce prix c'est pas
ma chaîne en fait ça là ma chaîne pas le
lien juste en dessous je décide dit
souvent là mais rarement dans le chat
alors pour bc2 il veut jouer sur la
colonne c'est jackpot images regarde
souvent sur youtube peu sur twitch hat a
découvert hier sur youtube pas regarder
quoi du coup soya on va voir si c'est
vrai ici vraiment à faire le taf moi
j'attends encore la position des blancs
c'est qu'il a fait retour à 7 pour ses
sets et bienvenue à toi aurait soya mais
tous qu'est ce que tu as regardé la
dernière vidéo aurait à elle était cool
c'était bien pour les gens qui débutait
c'était sympa tâche pour ces 6 et la
tourbe et 8 il va faire quoi mon self
veut faire b6 à mecha et ses 5 îles a
pas le temps devrait donc il peut encore
faire tourbe et 8 rbds et 6 kg et c5
encore ils bloquent tout et le cavalier
pas délogeables
il va remettre le france et quatre pour
ans c'est limite mais ces huit il
menacera pas bessette
ce qui va tenter un plan et si à rennes
leroy comme ça oui ce qui le ramène vers
le haut moi j'aurais eu le réflexe de
ramener vers le haut mais c'est mon côté
trop ambitieux mais il veut le ramener
par la red state mieux taillé le
cavalier bien placé un indélogeable ok
mon leroy qui vient jusque là le fou qui
va repartir en arrière avec le commencer
par âge et intermédiaires d'entrée le
petit piège que si tu prends la pièce le
pion fils adam
mais bon c'est fou j'ai 4 maintenant
peut-être qu'à y étaient 7 va être
jouable menace le pion bessette et
cavalli c5 leur tour pour essayer de le
choper
c'est chaud
la tour était pas vraiment fait risque
sur 1,17 et tour prend pour ces sept
échecs pardon et en plus elle était
protégée mais ok mannequin radio 5
carrier f7 bon alors c'est bien joué ça
de la part de celles encore ce qu'il
veut faire tourner à un jour effet des
cinq pour bien bloqué le fou comme il
faut détourner 6-3 6-3 ici roi ici vous
êtes maintenant la tour en baisse est
avec les de faire cavalier cinq
cavaliers vii et un fer 3 cet échec et
cette force et darwa f6 arrive à soie
ivoire il va prendre h7 et mireille
berger 4 le fou qui va venir en g7 et le
roi j'ai cinq pions gindou bien seul tir
et roigé six tours sète encore trois
sets pour prendre wife 5 ha il le fait
comme ça bien joué cette qui menace le
pion des cinq maintenant ok il encaisse
et omettre la tour en 1 6 3 c'est à tour
d'évitement le football qui ajuste pions
plus pour lui tant rêvé a plus de temps
celle qui va tomber grosse partie de
saulty 1-1 position est juste nul met
plus de temps
bah y'a rien à faire bien jouer avec
orange et 3 il a bien défendu après ça
va être très peu de temps sur la pendule
mais à mes bons juges tu peux rien c'est
la tour g1 et ses morts ouais une grosse
partie solti 7 qui a fait une grosse
belle partie 1 vraiment à ratier on
regarde un peu cap j'ai le droit qu ai
je droit qui a perdu mais c'est fait
mater quel jeu droit mais c'était une
partie agréable
allez on va suivre mort fillon l'a
jamais vu
mais la carence ses cinq plus derozan
chaîneurs jeu reprend un peu le chat et
j'ai trop rigoler sur ta vidéo de 1810
soya record en 2008 sans elle est
marrante cette vidéo attend encore
beaucoup à regarder l'amphi contre
fischer ouais mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est bobby fischer qui lagat et non
parce que là il a du matos en plus ces
menaces cavalière 3 d'un match de nice
il revient en f1 heikki et prend délicat
attend plus il peut en matériel et aussi
dame prend là qui menace ses atours f1
matin à paris le troll ah non c'est pas
mal pardon mais il ya cavalière froid
après et menaces damage de bons rails 3
c et damages de m'attendais ça se voyait
que ça ma tête c'était ma tante 3 pakito
fille vaut alors cette finale ça donne
quoi
joli la structure là y'a quoi y'a pus en
plus je pense que faire tu es ce que tu
fais tout rage s'est tué ce tour j'ai
trop tu prends tu te laisses bloquer le
roi ou du fairway f7 ouais y'a pas de
pions plus pour paquito est ce qu'elle
est vraiment ok tu vas faire f5 grecque
menace et f4
bien joué il va chercher du contre jeu
avec les blancs mais ça lui fasse de
fabrice et si on diffuse quelque part
dit non je commande juste l'après midi
est ce que tu fais des droits pour 1000
lots à main pas vraiment non bloque pas
on bloque pas les loups soya dans les
tournois et variés pas tour des salles
juste qu'ils gagnent assez bizarre de
rater ça regardez le roi plus rapprochée
de la tour et les tours bref cette eau
prochain et la partie qui s'est retourné
deux fois en l'espace d'un coup
donc là l'idée c'est surtout avec tours
prend b2 ou avec 3 pour soutenir une
tour et peut-être pour faire un match de
l'escalier
ok
e
ce que prendre des deux une option ici
tran b2 prend b2 prend f5
ok donc ça c'est pas une option donc
faut venir faire échec et reprotéger ce
pion échanger et jouer sur les pions qui
avance vite
c'est exactement ce que fait paquito
est-ce que je vais jouer aujourd'hui
soya et ce soir on va faire les parties
contre les abonnés à 20h et je suis pas
sûr que je joue aujourd'hui demain jour
un tournoi à 18h le title tuesday depuis
ses 18 ou 19 heures mais je crois que
c'est 18 heures
mais ce soir 20h on jouera contre les
abonnés twitch avec mathieu cornette
qu'un grand maître qui a été champion de
france bavarois des cinq noms mais là il
y avait tout re ba iv tour huit tours 33
c'est dommage en fait parce que
techniquement c'est pas si mal ce que
font les deux joueurs
honnêtement ils ont des bonnes idées
mais il y aura trop de tactique en un
coup mais là maintenant tour ces trois
ça donne quoi
sept nuls pour ces trois là while the
hidden juste pour ces deux tempos dans
ces cas il faut faire d échec par
derrière à fond parce que le roi pour se
cacher il doit partir et du coup vous
pourrez gratter le pluriel 3,3 f2 il
fait juste un cadeau au noir il donne
pour ses droits et enfin il donne tout
ouais trop de trop d'erreurs graves en
fait trop d'erreurs graves
alors vive lulu on va voir ce qui donne
contre hugo 30,94 termine scandinave
donc
voilà vidéo de bassa les fantastiques
on savait ni scandinave très bizarre
alors saddam pouvoir on arrive
finalement tant bien que mal dans une
finale où les noirs sont dans le dur il
ya égalité matérielle mais les deux
pions l'a doublé sur une colonne ouvert
c'est dangereux
en moins de deux moins sûr et papy
talent 17 avec ma tour
parce qu'en réalité ses pions là ils
sont pas très dangereux et je me dis que
j'aurais le temps de les prendre après
tout radevich pouvoir est ce que ça mais
bon ça doit aller 1 d'être fait que j'ai
3 toujours en fuite
rêvons tous tu donne quand même un peu
de jeux pan mais du coup il revient plus
ou moins là dedans avec deux trois temps
de perdu et ça va être un problème de
défendre ses pions ce que touré fuite du
coup si tu fais 3 ce que j'aime pas trop
c'est que ton roi il peut se retrouver
un peu bloqué encore que quand même
quand même faire roi d ici c'est je sais
pas je n'aime pas trop cette structure
pour les blancs mois il a filé un pion
avec les noirs ce qui est dommage
n'était pas du tout obligé de le donner
et maintenant f3 tour g 8 g 4 mais le
truc c'est qu'on aurait plutôt voulu
faire roi des six pour tenir tous les
pions
la parole qui était complètement gagnant
contre cette joie et afful retourner
elle est bon il est fort un seb
il est fort et ça lui julie z 82 29 pour
ceux qui t'ont joueurs préférés et c'est
toujours une question difficile soya
mais attendez je réponde un message
je crois qu'on a un message et l'étau
autour des 3 c'est bien je vais là parce
que la finale depuis qu'un pion de plus
ça gagne a toujours facilement
donc ça
ap
alors
cette finale répond de façon à les
gagnantes en septembre + salut trip
carmélites
non mr beaucoup de beaucoup de grands
joueurs tu as ta bobby fischer tata
caral cents à kasparov morphy capable en
cas tous les champions du monde en
réalité mais c'est difficile de de
parler d'un joueur puisque toutes les
finales d'options est loin les deux
gagnants parce que tu vas tu vas créer
des pions passé la petit coup de jets
simple à mon avis est 3e 5 même ses 3
500 corps mieux tu te places bien avec
le roi 3f set et j'ai cinq après charles
vii par angers 5 6 prend de l'âge tu
prendrais est allé deux pions passé ce
qui veut dire qu'ils seront jamais
prenable parce que dès qu'il prend lyon
derrière il ya suite de vente qui avance
et 6 pouces
donc s'il prend pas un petit coup droit
des six et là c'est un autre angle et
noir peuvent pas bouger droit ni en f6
niro cet exemple c'est un peu si tu
joues tu perds et du coup il est obligé
de quitter la protection du curieux 6 et
donc ça a gagné face si le mans alors on
peut aller voir qu'au lieu de bip bip
tient 14
on l'a vu dans le chat tout alors là ils
jouent contre j jv qui est très
dangereux
comment rejoindre tournoi je vais te
mettre le lien vrai nom car la scène
beau joueur
non mais chaque champion du monde sa et
chaque joueur d'exception à apporter
quelque chose aux échecs et top 3 allez
je mettrais kasparov quand même fischer
étals pour le style
les joueurs que j'aime le moins graves
c'est pas par avance joueur que j'aime
pas ah c'est pas mal parce que le cavaly
detroit il se fait enfermer le carry
your saints car il peut plus revenir en
d3 et donc c'est de nouveau gagner pour
les noirs puent nathan qui s'est pris
une leçon en finale bah ouais pour pina
taurin faut bosser tes final je pense
tout reprend des deux du coup parce que
tu t'es donné la casse ckt fou prend 1,5
et 2 pièces à vos six points et une tour
ça en vaut que 5
est-ce que la russie participé à l'euro
de foot je sais pas il n'y aura pas de
refus de toute façon cette année pas de
lascars en top 3 ans non mais guérissent
quand même un excellent joueur
d'ailleurs ses joueurs que tu aimes le
moins mais bon c'est des classements ça
peut dépendre des moments ça peut
dépendre de beaucoup de choses et le
deuxième bobby fischer soya kasparov
fischer étals on va dire mais bon
j'aurais pu se mettre à l'équipe joël
faut être capable en cage s'est pas
assez trop dur à dire mais je croise les
doigts pour le tour de france est dur le
tour de france aux siens juste pour que
je débute mais quand tu commences
regarde plutôt les parties de mort fils
est parti de capable en cas ça détend
c'est faux vous peut-être commencé avec
d'autres joueurs quoi à parier une guêpe
là
à tan tan tan tan tan tan tan il ya une
gamme de niveaux 2 là j'ai pas si vous
l'entendez mais il ya une gamme de
niveaux de là c'est pas drôle du tout je
vais ouvrir le balcon j'ai essayé de la
dégager
mais là c'est pas drôle du tout là je ne
rigole plus là c'est une brigade de
niveau 2 et elle est très énervé je vous
le dis tout de suite c'est je ne m'amuse
pas du tout là elles volent de partout à
l'air très nerveuse ça se peut que je
quitte le stream à un moment pour la
virer vous pouvez voir partir et courir
si elle vient vers moi mais je suis pas
du tout rassuré en fait franchement je
suis pas du tout rassuré elle va alors
assez agressive j'ai pas elle vole je
sais pas ce qu'elle fait en plus j'avais
semi ouvert la fenêtre quoi je m'étais
dis à personne qui va rentrer je
l'entends se rapprocher j'aime pas ça je
suis un peu on sur les gars en plus j'ai
rien sous la main j'ai pas une serviette
j'ai rien la gamme mobile sans qu'on
apprenne tu es tranquille
ouais mais le truc c'est que je sais pas
je ne peux même pas ce qu'elle fait
mon pull j'ai pas de budget quoi j'ai eu
et j'ai un t-shirt là pas loin ok déjà
un truc sous la main non les abeilles ne
me font pas peur mais la guêpe un peu
alors à temps elle s'approche de la
fenêtre mais non mais sort j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est sortie je suis
pas sûr ou alors elle s'est posée
tiens on va regarder à rio non non on
est toujours là sur le micro dans
arrêter ça non non les abeilles j'ai pas
peur du tout en fait
les abeilles j'ai fait même pas
attention mais je n'arrive pas à voir
wall et j'aime pas du tout j'arrive pas
être détendu quoi du coup maintenant
vous savez ce qui me ment ps attendait
attendait s'approche de moi j'aime pas
du tout ça mais des cages mais retourne
dans la forêt quoi j'en sais rien moi
attends attends attends elle se
rapproche des essais ou froid c'est ouf
ça y est les parties je souffle mais je
souffle non il est revenu [ __ ] mais de
plus en plus proche de moi quoi je sais
pas quoi faire elle m'a le stress quoi
c'est une honte ce stream vous allez me
prendre vais vous dire je suis un
fragile qua non mais j'ai failli perdre
la vue une fois à cause d'une guêpe et
du coup elles me font un peu peur elle
va avec piqué près de l'oeil j'avais un
oeil au beurre noir pendant des semaines
et du coup j'aime pas trop
du coup j'aime pas trop mal mais surtout
je l'entends voler autour là ça m'énerve
baltringue
ouais je bouge avait été piqué proches
de l'oeil et depuis j'ai peur peur peur
peur c'est pas le mot mais juste
normalement je suis avec mon t-shirt de
lui [ __ ] des coups en fait pour quel
parti j'aurais fait peur et ça venir
d'entendre ce bourdonnement là chez
fillon sera pour les secours n'ont en
plus tu parles peut rentrer dans ta
bouche dans les manades ma soeur s'était
piqué dans l'oreille une gamme c'est pas
nouveau l'emballage peut se faire qu
elle fait du bruit attendez je vais
aller voir la situation chez pascal vous
allez devant une porte
elles ont la porte de sortie du studio
je sais pas elle va aller de l'autre
côté par des gt2 c'est d'aller à dégager
j'essaie de la dégager allez va t'en il
ne revient plus c'est bon j'ai géré j'en
avais marre
mais non c'était une grosse gaffe je
demande si t'es pas un petit frelons en
fait je sais pas ce que c'était mais
c'était quand même à laver une certaine
taille
c'était pas une petite ce n'est pas une
petite guêpe qui prend des seins parce
que ça marchait je pense qu'il prend des
saints qui est d'un prend des cinq
toulon en avant de façon layada angers7
mais au pire a même été reprend des cinq
français 3 ça je comprends mais d'un
projet set et après re par contre après
roi qu'il aurait pu faire rope aussi
peut-être parce que sur quel dessein
qu'il ya dame prend et france et 3
cplussur échec dû comprendre dut prendre
ces 3 voilà du coup il a filé un pion
par avion
non mais je sais je sais pas si c'était
une guêpe mais les gags sont agressifs
de toute façon non mais j'y connais rien
mais un truc de chez pas ça peut être un
frelon anti frelon asiatique non les
frelons asiatiques sont vraiment gros
j'aurais couru en dehors de la pièce
j'aurais eu super peur j'aurais eu super
peur mais vous vous n'avez pas peur des
caps pas peur jean vous n'êtes pas
inquiet c'est une grosse gate qui rôdent
autour de vous dans une pièce
un peu et forrest également là j'étais
calme et juste au bout d'un moment ça
vous saoule pas moi c'est les temps qui
me font flipper moi je suis toujours mal
autant pour pina tort ma femme s'est
fait piquer une fois par des temps genre
ils sont mis à trois ou quatre ils ont
attaqué et c'est vrai qu'elle avait des
salles piqûre pendant peut-être un ou
deux mois
comprend pas en fait parce que les
abeilles sont tellement sympas
on a des tonnes de temps commander une
pizza en pleine mêlée temps pourquoi ils
attaquent les gens fait je comprends pas
c'est quoi leur objectif bondé vient un
peu des échecs mais faut dire qu'on fait
beaucoup de live à midi mais pourquoi
pourquoi en fait ce qui est pourquoi l
tat qu'en fait ça je comprends pas parce
que les abeilles elles sont sympas je
dirais elles n'ont aucun intérêt à datta
khel t'attaques pas mais pourquoi est-ce
que pourquoi est ce que les abeilles les
temps et toutes ces merdes tata qu'en
fait ils se nourrissent du sang
non mais vraiment à l'étang se
nourrissent du sang c'est n'importe quoi
bon du coup il change les dames et gagne
la finale - tiens on va regarder
[Musique]
tiens l'ex versons tient ce fait
longtemps qu'on a pas vu alex va se
repasser la partie mais les gags du coup
c'est quoi l'intérêt des abeilles pour
se défendre il des nuggets 100 pour se
nourrir ok mais là est pourquoi
exception agréé cfa je ne m'adresse pas
ça fait échanger massivement
j'ai skié en faisant une grosse
s'inquiétant j'ai pris la chemise mais
juste j'étais j'étais un peu juste un
pensionnaire quoi tu t'entends ce
bourdonnement donc cette finale à ce qui
pourrait être considéré comme un peu
faible ou pas à ta cave à la casse des
cartes pour le cavalier mais ça doit
être rien du tout quoique mais le cas
est en d4 le pion au f4 montre laurent 3
ça doit être rien mais avec les blancs
tu peux tenter de semis pressé je sais
pas
l'utopie c'est europe 1 qui ont par les
abeilles et des dieux non les abeilles
non
quel c'est quoi cette non coiffure mais
il faut que j'aille chez le coiffeur
ailleurs à iron kurt hectic mais j'ai
pas comme tu l'as remarqué peut-être
c'est pas facile en ce moment mon tour
prend b3 je me demande si ce truc c'est
qu'il a ce un compte de qui bloque mais
de toute façon tu pourras faire b6 à
tout moment je sais pas si je pense pas
préféré jouer avec les noirs mais c'est
peut-être moi qui abusent se doit est
rien du tout je ne sais rien du tout
c'est sur mes jambes
est-ce que techniquement je suis pas
content en or le pion à passer mais bon
si on réussit à échanger b comptera
peut-être à un jour peut être pénis y
avait plus les tours sur l'échiquier en
fait les noirs seraient mieux parce que
b 6 puis on prend cavaliers prend et le
pion à est passée et là tu crois aussi
tu veux faire quoi qui est peut-être
tour 10 6 3 points f5 tourcoing 17 pour
provoquer un peu les choses
c'est pas con après cinq ans d'essais
3,6 pour protéger tous ses sept tours b
5 at on prend tout reprend et c'est
complètement nul
s'il vat ambitions peut-être joué g5 a
su retomber sicile à toi f6 ça j'avais
pas vu j'avais vu jusque là et je
n'avais pas vu tour f 6 et bien joué
alex versons du cou qui défend
latéralement le truc mais ça doit rester
nul quoi qu'il en soit il faut qu'il
pousse de ce côté là c'est tenter cette
fois qu'il en voit un peu ses pions exil
autres à lui prendre là qu'ils
réussissent à manger de l'autre côté
quoi
[Musique]
quelques brèves 5 il l'a jamais aimé la
tourbe et 6 3
il le voit pas et maintenant ils
laissent aller vers le pur et là ça va
être gagnant pour les noirs maintenant
parce qu'il a laissé s'approcher du pion
peut-être un petit coup de lâche 5
mais oui c'est de plus en plus de toute
façon mais ça devrait gagner pour alex
si réussie qui attend 5 échecs quand
même important bond à trois questions m
la tour f 3 il va la perdre autant les
rois p3a trois rois ton pions et après
tu feras tout rêve de tourbe et de et
enlèvera le roi il veut déjà faire un
pont mais c'est trop tôt allez à 3 à la
ici semble être quoi il plie pour être
protégés de faim il pourrait ramener le
pion à de leroy et seulement après se
couvrir à les tours b 3 3 il fait trop
de prophylaxie à alex et prend et a3 et
des pions prend vite
wen en temps j'ai trois brefs croix
jusqu'à 3,4 même bon ça reste nul mais
il s'est trop casser la tête en fait il
aurait pu faire beaucoup plus simple est
la tour 1 ces salles parce qu'il a
forcément prêts move c'est dommage il
aurait juste dû faire plus simple
montesson remonter son pion fait je sais
pas quand il ya eu mon avis tout en
admettant qu'ils prennent pas genre à 3
tours ici échec 3 2 tours ici roi p2
touriste hiroire un tour ici
à deux et après tu ramènes la tour peu
importe où tu fais roi bien il fait un
échec fait ça et tu dames julie ipad
contre l'autre côté c'était beaucoup
plus simple que de se casser la tête à
faire des ponts des machins à gauche à
droite il a perdu trop de temps c'est
dommage quoi c'est dommage alors arrivé
citron chocolat contre mots de chat on
va pas sûr non pas de rester très
longtemps sur cette partie parce qu'il
ya déjà du matos et il ya cette idée
avec les blancs qui a l'air assez cool
une version qui est technique en finale
ouais tu t'es trop casser la tête avec
ça c'est pas malin ce que tu faisais
c'est juste super compliqué la vie
tu t'es juste compliquer la vie qu'elle
y avoir maintenant il ya jean fou prend
dame prend dame f7 ses classiques 3
bougez tour h3c un match classique donc
je vous montre les blancs monts loire il
valoir
ça va nous permettre à l'heure à voir
des gens qu'on n'a pas eu tout à hadopi
nous pas des strikers contre fable the
fate fabrice ça c'est intéressant comme
partie notre fab de fab flatte de fabre
qui jouait là il n'avait pas joué depuis
le depuis jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait
pas encore vu fap de fab
enfin enfin warfare 2 fabrice et saluera
exil qui salua tout ce chahut tonton
salut à toi
mais peut-être un peu comme ces cinq
peut être intéressant ouais mais si
j'aime pas trop il est ce qui a aidé 6
peut-être qu avait lieu 4 était une idée
pour essayer de contrôler la case des si
justement la tour e sept cavaliers 8 qui
peut encore call mater avoir sinaï
scénarii natchez comme france ferait de
terreur et salue gris 1063 qu'avait lieu
4 m'annonça à contretemps du coup il ya
eu huit ans l'air non à il prend pas à 8
il prend 1,4 oui bon ça qui gagne un
pion j'en ai quand même pris la calloc'h
ce que le pion des quatre ans quand
l'avancé ou là la fin de fabrice o c'est
la cata ah c'est la cata pour fat de
fabrice c'est la cata allez un cap j'ai
le droit est ce qu'on va pouvoir voir
une partie il a les blancs qu'elle
jouerait complètement foutue qu'elle
faisait le drapeau rebelle
déjà pareillement son affreux duchesse
nouvelle et il faut gagner games a alors
laissé voir une partie qui vient plus du
maintien l'asm il a arrêté le combat il
a dû partir
tiens carioca naïve ivoire dans le chat
tout à l'heure ce que ça va qu'est ce
que ça donne pour lui on va voir ça
est-ce qu'il s'en sort pas mal
alors ça fait 4 5 il a gagné deux
parties la 4.6 4 6 6 3 qui est fou c'est
cinq essais 3 kiev si ça fait une petite
genre de quatre cavaliers thierry
italienne et a joué les pions des six et
qui a aidé sa cause il s'est pris ce
truc qui est pas cool
alors ça a essayé de l'attaquer
ok c'est compliqué comme parti il s'est
pris le cloître qui était pas sympa
quand même fait j'ai quatre ses 600 g
lampions tran ah ouais ça envoi côté
blanc l'as toujours pareil hein en
défense il faut bien calculer droite
mais l'avantagé c'est que la tourelle
coup j'ai cinq ans avec la lampe pas
rentrer et qui a à f pour un f2 qui
menace pour en l'a donc sa mort est
vachement rassurer avec les noirs parce
qu'en gros je me serais dit si j'ai le
temps de faire de même 6 x 6 je couvre
tout après mais je vais plutôt me droit
je suis peut-être je sais pas on va voir
et peut-être prendre des 4
j'aime plutôt me drôle je suis parce que
s'il fait ton g7 tu es obligé de faire
droit à suite on va voir il est pas très
bien longtemps 6000 fond avec 5 par
contre les tours france et 2 qui arrive
ouais ça peut pas mal se passer pour les
noirs là
peut-être tu peux même prendre h si ce
que tu as tu accueilles mange tout cas
ce que tu rajoutes une blague là tu as
toutes les pièces blanc juste faut pas
hésiter un faut les prendre sur échec et
rasé pour raser la tour la pression là
est complètement gagnante questions sur
un complètement saoul côté énoncer une
partie qui doit bien se passer pour lui
regardait il lui reste 38 secondes c'est
pas sûr qu'ils gagnent 1 il joue bien
mais après il est peut-être un peu lent
et pranger cette île à hilal matos mais
[Musique]
la partie se passe plutôt bien pour lui
et il est très mal autant et plus
enchaîné il a gagné vrai il monte il a
mille partie sympa mais n'en 200 points
elo tu sais c'est ça peut gagner à
gauche à droite sur une partie on peut
pas juger un ace que qu'elle faisait le
droit du coup ça me fait marrer en fait
j'ai le droit bordel alors c'est la
petite trompeau avec la variante gf qui
est plutôt bien qu'elle faisait le droit
mais qui a réussi à avoir une position
intéressante à jouer
il avait pas à 837 lots il avait 980 et
qui la reine
allez vas-y je voulais pas jouer du
rapide aujourd'hui mais je me fais
arrêter un petit 10 mai 2010 fred
camargue ouais on est combien en et 121
aujourd'hui ouais t'as du magouër non
mais normal parce que l'on voit pas bien
les lots qui d'autre a vu le match j'ai
même vu hier soir avec beauté j'ai pas
vu s'attaquent à leurs sages ou acquis
alors ce match contre avec sandra
ces quatre j'aime bien coût des noirs
parce qu'il vient se prendre la case d3
pour le cavalier le pion est assez bien
protégé
moi je fais le raid chez botez à 21 23
heures à 2 heures du mat
est-ce que je suis père tard maxime
et du coup quel score
lourd
normalement il dormait pour voter à ces
pas étonnant
tabanou on a on a fait le reste il va il
était était 23 heures je pense j'imagine
peut-être ces petites baies 3 était une
option pour les blancs pour miner un peu
le pion c4 attaqué le cavalier dame
s'est dit pourquoi pas aussi un mail
mais la dame en face de la tour
ça peut être ça peut être un peu
compliqué
quelques cavaliers des why not s'en
prend aux cavale kébé 4 émanant de tati
peut aller chercher le pion à vii cas
cette thématique dans ses variantes
vous êtes à jouer aux échecs des fois
oui j'essaie de suçons streame à et une
partie en font elle chantait des
chansons irlandaises
je crois peut-être frime beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup hein
du coup au bout d'un moment quand tu
stream 6 7 heures par jour tous les
jours c'est dur de ne faire que des
échecs
franchement tu tourne un peu en rond
c'est notamment pour ça que j'étais un
peu déçu hier qu'ils aient pas eu la
reina et c'est parce que ça permet de
faire des d'avoir des choses à stream et
puis de faire des petits événements
c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu déçu
qu'ils organisent paraît grand-chose
chaise comme wes a peut-être elle va
être streamé à entre six et huit heures
par jour
donc au bout d'un moment elle fait ça
tous les jours tout le temps oui ebit sa
4è
normalement tu as ta [ __ ] a plus grand
chose à raconter un même là tu as les
arénas demi dit on regarde un peu les
parties ont passé un moment ensemble un
monde assez difficile de raconter 6
passes sur l'échiquier tout le temps oui
quitte à organiser ses propres tour avec
joie ce qu'on fait là mais après tu vas
fort et que ça crée de la hype avec des
joueurs forts qui viennent avec un prize
pool et tout ça c'est en ça que c'est
cool et les arénas de choses comme t'as
pas vraiment besoin de beaucoup d'argent
en fait
t'as pas besoin tu mets tu mets 200
euros de prix presse comme c'est pas
énorme et puis tu fais l'aréna c'est un
peu c'est un peu dommage pas
ouais faut calculer analysé parler et
tout pendant six heures c'est beaucoup
utopie sais c'est difficile de beaucoup
d'esprit mais les déconnexions ces
matches comme on nous avait failli je
sais pas iron
moi je suis pas vraiment déconnecté j'ai
pas eu trop de problèmes jusqu'à
maintenant je sais pas ouais vas y toi
sur des variantes mais c'est les
warrants que les gens aiment pas trop
généralement si tu le fais très petites
doses
c'est cool mais à grandes doses des gens
aiment pas trop les variantes et moi non
plus l'air inquiet français trois tons
france et roi dame prend des deux et il
va récupérer la tourelle faire bref un
peut-être mesdames des trois rois et un
cavalier eux deux et c'est la cata il a
raté le pion à vii dans la partie oui
c'est dans une partie qui vient de
commencer s'installe siècle des cats et
5 dci cheese frac car ça qui a été de
risque est trois concerts normal
cet indice est supérieur de jouer en
stream remarquer qu'on perd quasi 200
points
on va après compte aller l'habitude
super peut-être entre 50 et 100 points
on va dire ça comme ça mais oui
évidemment parce qu'au lieu de calculer
tu parles
donc tu perds du temps moi je dirais sur
les partitions et qu'elle joue ça coûte
entre 10 et 20 secondes et ça ralentit
un petit peu mais c'est énorme 10 20
secondes
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que tu toujours
mal autant et chariots soya peut-être ça
le fond la raison tu expliquer ce que tu
fais du coup ça prend du temps à le dire
et tu perds du temps
j'essaie effect 960 j'aime pas du tout
bref on s'habitue et moi je trouve ça
sympa mais il faut s'habituer
sigrid chioukh stream est vrai bailly se
serait finir caisse ou régionaux
vêtements et je pense pas tu vois la
même chose est ce que si je faisais que
ça ma vie je pourrais l'être peut-être
mais vu que je vais pas le faire je le
serai pas donc c'est très difficile à
dire mais ce que je peux dire à coup sûr
c'est que j'aurai jamais pu rentrer dans
le top 100 mondial quoique je fasse ça
c'est sûr
cherkaoui streamer ecoplus ouais tu peux
ça existe toujours les parties à 4 à
haut niveau non je pense pas que ça
existe avec un petit air funkel font ça
n'a jamais existé je pense que ça n'a
jamais existé sur mettre le lien du
tournoi le 8 5 ha ça toujours été un jeu
pour s'amuser la carioca qui est très
désagréable
le caraïbe et trois étaient pas très
bien placé dans la partie après je peux
comprendre ils voulaient menacé fois à 5
et le fait qu'à mes cahiers des deux
fous b6 et le cavalier repasse par ed
troyer rebondit sur échec et puis on
prend b6 celle eurobonds qui fait mal
leurs bombes sur échec ça fait mal parce
que t'as pas le temps de prendre des 8es
du coup palmarès de l'opération les
blancs perdu une pièce
bien joué bien joué
là c'est fini on va changer de parti on
va les pois c'est quelqu'un d'autre
tu allais pour un tien poupine à tort
contre barbarian c'est intéressant ça
barbarian qui encore leader du thon il
est vraiment fort ce barbarian il est
vraiment très très fort barbarian
barbarian encore leader mais n'arrête
pas d'être leader enfin paquito vient de
lui passer devant mais c'est quand même
le et im tournoi où il est oui caracole
en tête mais contre poutine a tort rien
ne va être simple un don qui a fait une
petite viennoise poopy frank zappa
kilani en pls
donc
ok kg 3 il est changé mais la finale
elle est bien mieux pour les noirs parce
que les pions doublé là ils sont moches
après tu peux espérer pourra jouer avec
f4 te débarrasser des pions doublé à
voir cette structure-là et tiers-état
petit nul à tu peux espérer tirer ta
petite nul
peut-être prendre 20 kg 5 ok je
comprends f4f 4 et tour 17 sûrement
j'imagine salue la beuverie bonne
journée à toi à tonton
ballard et de rentrer là dedans alors ça
c'est dommage parce qu'en fait tu peux
prendre trois de toute façon la
fourchette elle va pas s'envoler ce que
la brière du coup tu perds en plus le
pur f2 donc la bataille allemand ça fait
quoi ré ils allaient tour il va devoir
faire ses trois des quatre il aurait pas
eu le temps de façon garder tous les
pions je pense il aurait perdu b2 auquel
réitérant ses six touches le fou
si on prend roi g2 est fou prend m23
problème de ces bizarres food et 4 comme
décision ok j'avais plutôt prions ces
systèmes que du coup tu lui d'où l'avion
tu lis ça y est la structure c'est
dommage par exactement la même position
avec les carriers échanger baissé bon là
ça va déjà faire cavalier froid et tu
vas l'avenir mais c'est quand même
dommage de ne pas avoir pris en c6 est
abîmée la structure cela ressemble
parfois vous vous compliquer la vie les
gars
parfois vous compliquer la vie vous fait
pas le truc simple en fait j'ai essayé
de jouer originale aux échecs
rappelez-vous d'un truc et vous pouvez
très bien voir sur mes stream d'ailleurs
c'est que dès que j'essaie de jouer
original ou quoi ça marche pas cet échec
c'est un jeu bizarre où l'original fin
pas bizarre et singes ou l'originalité
pas payer la faudra en revient en d2 je
pense car il y avait quatre tours h1 et
jouer h 4 se débarrasser de ses pions h
là bas si possible
mais oui n'oubliez pas que
être original n'est pas forcément et
n'est souvent pas gage de réussite aux
échecs
prot
sûrement tour h1 sûrement tourache un
bon tour f1 pourquoi pas mais joli très
faim tu te mets caméra db5 dq bouge le
roi le moindre échec tu gagnes la tour
et maintenant il ya ghb tu mens pourquoi
il n'a pas pris le pion je suis le mange
blizzard est comme ça tu ramènes h3
bizarre bizarre bon
kg 3 j'aime bien me bloque le pion et il
protège la tourbe qui s'enlève de tous
les problèmes de découverte
sacha qui se bat mais c'est plutôt sympa
je raconte des joueurs plus forts stade
cheikh peut-être trois des quatre rois
des captures qui est le 2e acteur clef
c'est chiant je déteste cette tour
dégagement à 7 tours mais la main
quelque part où près de 4 kg 3 pour rien
faire pourquoi pas mais refait kg 3
tempo en fait ouais voilà ça c'est bien
ça ça j'aime bien je bouge pas tu fais
rien mais mal autant tour un tempo tu
peux pas échangés ici et sur wave 4
grillage cinq échecs et maintenant tours
ok tu reviens angers avec la tour il va
te mettre la tour en f4 cavalli g3
reviens tu étais content en fait qui les
fâche 5
c'est dans l'intérêt des blancs turmel
qui en g3 tata cash 5 carats et f4 et il
revient en f1 et la tour et maintenant
h5 et en l'air ça tu es plutôt content
avec les blancs mais il peut pas
réaliser ça rapidement mais il est moins
fort elle se reprend le carillon f4
annonce est prise prises et tour f5
il va perdre l'option alors à venir le
prendre il ya les deux pions passé lié
et il va perdre sa chance c'est
peut-être tourache un 3ème tour h-13 h
trois tours f1 vraiment là c'est noir
c'est dommage il a pas mal joué pour
pina tort mais où il passait de temps
trop lent notre ami poutine a tort mais
après on peut comprendre jeu contre un
adversaire plus fort il a quand même
fait une excellente partie puisqu'il a
tenu et après manqué juste de vitesse
quoi il monté juste de vitesse bon c'est
quand même pas mal hein c'est quand même
pas si mal et ça lui maxime karl juste
car lui ça tient ce jour le chat you
tube désolé les gars vous ai pas trop
jusqu'à maintenant c'était pas mal de
gens aujourd'hui
ouais
affaire de fabrice qui en sûr
aujourd'hui on le voit dans le tchat
pakito fimo atteint scénario fut
intéressante sur wade sirois ses cadres
qui ont fait boire 17,3 c7 ça va faire
un statu quo s'il est bien on vient
danser cats trois des six élèves auprès
du roi décidément a droit à ses quatre
nous pesons si les noirs bouche de
n'importe où ils n'ont pas de coût pour
protéger le pion et inversement si c'est
les blancs qui font race et 4 les noirs
jours on a des six essais les blancs qui
n'ont pas de coût aura bougé puis on
prend des 5es roi reprend des 5
donc ils sont obligés de faire un statu
quo et ça fait nul intéressant
intéressant à tryphon tient tryphon qui
a 10 sur 10 on n'a pas vu jusque là et
qui est une photo du père dos du
professeur tournesol en photo en photo
de profil sain patoche sympa tâche le
professeur tournesol avec un petit rocco
posé qui vient d'une scandent-ils bien
sûr
ce soit récusé la souris c'est pleutre
fap de fabrice accusé de plâtrerie les
papes l'autre face de fabrice nantes
fait longtemps qu'ils sur la chaîne il
ne peut pas être pleutres
mais 3 + 2 ou 5 + 0 ça peu près où is
who is who le grand clown ont ils sous
le grand classique le grand classique le
clouage c'est dommage ça c'est dommage
le problème c'est l'interface entre la
souris la chaise de dia et ron cook
coeur cette technique
j'arrive pas à ça va élire bien son
pseudo faut que tu te fasses un bon
set-up fameux fabrice faut que tu rage
le tournoi dès demain affable de fabas
les on se chauffe là demain on te voit à
fond et bonjour à doom mais vraiment des
préaux complètement différente relais
stream là le soir sur bitstream et les
scribes la journée sur chaise com fr
c'est très étrange en fait ou alors
c'est moi qui ai blitz entrailles hard
et qui regarde pas trop le chat ne
semble vraiment les pseudos différents
stages et une équipe boom dans le chat
il a dû faire un point
café d'un statique ça peut être mon
téléphone qui ont fait parfois parce que
je l'avais laissée mais c'est vrai que
j'ai finalisé ce que je vais finalisé en
fait
bonjour je suis une veille tu m'as
jamais vu ces riches travaillent non je
ne vais pas il ya quelques personnes qui
apparemment ne connaissent pas le nom
mais je pense qu'ils connaissent mais
juste qui des personnes différentes
c'est quand l'esprit de cette semaine
bitstream ce soir 20h avec matthew
cornette demain 18h le title tuesday
mercredi normalement rien jeudi 20h30
normalement arena bitstream a fait feu
vendredi partie pédagogique avec fabu
qu'avec moi ou je sais pas samedi et
dimanche
even caritatif avec médecins sans
frontières et il y aura à mathieu
cornette etienne bacrot maxime vachier
lagrave et femmes
peut-être en fout c'est cette maturité à
rodez en gros voilà un fossé s'est
depuis tout à l'heure c'est sympa mais
bon les va faire tout reprend c'est
celle d'après tous gagnants de toute
façon tien bo biecher 00 de higgs a dit
qu'il avait gagné le tournoi et suite à
vos recommandations
hier soir j'ai commencé à regarder
hunter x hunter l'animé j'ai pas trop
quoi en penser pour le moment donc c'est
moyen mais je sais pas encore dans son
genre c'est pas mal mais a il pas malade
il fait mal la potiche à la fac et prend
2,5
il fait très mal
allez on vous conseille d'arrêter hunter
x hunter j'ai un peu regardé bon
truqué pays c'est que c'est encore un
gamin de 12 ans qui est au milieu du
truc en fait c'est un vrai quelques
épisodes hockey d'ailleurs vous prend 17
pib si ce clasico
des cela j'ai pas encore une des salles
les regarde je les regardais deux fois
oumorou ce type ici s'ils veulent forcer
à faire oui naturel
oui du bruit ne fait pas du tout alors
il ya une raison je suis alors dit non
il y avait six meilleurs coups depuis
toutes à l'arrêt juste il n'a pas vu
mais là ça devrait aller quand même deux
pions passé comme ça l'arena est
commencé depuis une heure il reste 10
minutes
death note c ou fin mais tu vois bernard
caux si c'est pas des bébés quoi céder
adulte tien et 17 oui mais bon là on
fait tout marche car il est 17 et
peut-être damas cet échec et sa rentrée
voilà ça se passe quand même plutôt pas
mal pour bobby fischer 02 mai suivant
combien de temps son adversaire lui fait
jouer la partie c'est peut-être ça
ternit y aura peut-être pas le temps il
va peut-être gagner le tournoi
mais one piece c'est vraiment bien ou
pas très jeune par le one piece want is
one piece
c'est hyper lent il ya déjà neuf cents
épisodes croyais à 40 milliards que quoi
et de sept pendant ce trop long
cissé en échec 6 beaucoup beaucoup trop
long
on va puis ça rend bien et son besoin de
cuche puis-je aller recommençait bien
aux 390
et donc c'est barbarian qui est leader
du truc mais barbarian il est fort c'est
tout un art il est vraiment vraiment
bien optimisé pour pour ce format il est
vraiment bon pour ce format le barbare
barbarian aller qui suivait déjà une
vidéo bitstream de l'époque des arènes
richesse c'est pour vous dire c'est pour
vous dire c'est ça qui la rend si forte
c'est ça qui le rend si puissant menacé
matelas bas
et bernard firmin team17 quoi ça parle
imbert heures que c'est un gars tu ya
une vie de merde c'est un genre de
fantaisie moyen âge et en gros x rite
avec tout le monde mais il serait
vraiment bien en fait et du coup il a qu
un objectif s'effrite avec des gens
enfin il sait rien faire d'autre que se
battent quoi et une grosse épée
j'ai toujours su de quoi ça parlait
vraiment en gros bazar c'est ça mais je
gagnais très énervé en fait il ajoutant
très énervé bon là il reste quatre
minutes normalement
jusqu'au canal sur le roi il encore plus
badass que ken le survivant de l'enfer
ouais c'est arrivé à les clichois et
bien sûr je pense c'est le meilleur
moment dans les clips il faut dire que
très agréable et très énervé
puis résumé une grosse épée prisé alors
au csii l'animé le manga sont bien j'ai
un peu fait les deux après que je
n'avais pas trop le temps je n'ai plus
faim en animé mais le manga est bien
aussi je n'ai pas le temps et c'est trop
long faut vraiment avoir du temps elle
va se faire mater il reste quoi il reste
2 35
il va pas pouvoir empêcher le mat en
fait assez bien joué par marianne qui va
réussir à mater de la mater la barbare
donc barbarian qui à finir premiers une
nouvelle fois je pense qu'à force
barbarian il va même mérité une série de
vidéos sur le pion isolé un à force de
raser à lorànt deutsch man fantastique
donc il reste deux minutes arba et manu
guignard à maïga qui veut faire tomber
son adversaire il est malin ce manu il
est malin de chez malin il est très
malin manu il est très très malin manu
jous la pendule
il est fort le menu ouais il va faire
tomber manu allez va même mater manulife
ou aux 4 ayé force manu oh non il fait
pas mates en un il fait tomber à il est
méchant mais il veut même pas fait il
veut fait il voulait faire tomber la
nier aya bobby fischer ce qui est revenu
à égalité avec barbarian il va falloir
faire des nuls à houla barbarian y la
pièce de plus les phoques am et il fait
pas les vies de son adversaire du coup
c'est un peu dommage parce que
l'objectif c'est de faire annuler rapide
là et si bobby fischer deuil sont à tous
les deux à 59 n'est pas le cas sont mais
ils sont tous les deux à 59
et si bobby fischer mais je prends pas
tu y ailles la 60e il fait des durs non
il va se faire raser par bobby qui fait
des nuls barbarian qui va faire deuxième
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe propose nul
propose nul propose nul bobby fischer ii
il va faire le cavalier il va faire sa
vomissure dont on ne connait non à la
whey il essaye de faire la nuit rapide
ross a devancé reconnaît pas la faire
comme j'ai fait à amman en fait poussé
cinq travaille à trois pions problème
donnant il raté barbarian nul ne sait
pas là nul il est pareillement 20e coup
et c'est bobby fischer ii qui gagne
aïe aïe aïe bobby fischer 2 tu as fait
quatre ans victoires 0 défaite et sept
nuls à la fin pour mettre les points
ayé malin ce mobile chargeur
à la fouille de bobby fischer ii c'est
bien joué ça c'est bien joué ça on aime
c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau jeu
bobby et ouais ça on aime j'aime bien le
voir ça il était malin ce que les
moindres roy paci toi ouais mais bon
honnêtement un petit peu un petit peu
claqué aujourd'hui après tous les scream
du week end
donc si ça ne te dérange pas je vais
aller me reposer un petit peu surtout
que ce soir on est de retour avec
mathieu cornette pour les seuls du coup
donc sera sur la chaîne bitstream vous
avez lien juste en dessous si vous
n'êtes toujours pas follower et puis on
se retrouverait à 20h et ça ne vous
inquiétez pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer
t'inquiète pas
en tout cas c'était bien cool on s'est
bien amusé et on se retrouve demain ciao
l'élite